what was your plan back
there it's like a 14-hour drive to get
to Santa Fe didn't think that far ahead
to be honest dad you're pretty out of
shape
[Music]
though are you
hungry a sweet tooth you got from
me
uh is that all I got from
you somebody order a stripper
can I get you anything I'll Drink a
[Music]
Beer oh hey oh okay let's go no we're
just having a conversation excuse me 12
hours ago 12 hours ago you
OD trust me this path you're on is not
worth it what do you care you're an
addict guess who I've learned that
from
window I've been there and um my life
started to slip away I just couldn't
stop I didn't really know what it meant
to be a
father but I would like to get to know
you why would I ever trust you you've
never been there for me Dad
I'm just trying to find my
[Music]
[Applause]
daughter live your
life there's something greater something
better come
on come on I don't care what they say
I'm in love with you they try to pull me
away but they don't know the
truth